what oh no it's a galactus
you got one on the hook
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my god this
car is savage oh my god
welcome back to new rock stars rick and
morty season five episode five
a morty ken grick bt paired hellraiser
pleasure pain logic with american
graffiti ferris bueller's day off
revealing that rick's
car has a personality all her own far
beyond
keeping summer safe including galactus
hunting
how many galactus has she killed and why
is she killing is there a deeper reason
she's hunting these deities
one that might make us say what the
this is we explained our rick and morty
after show where your cringes that are
over analysis feel
so good to us
make us feel so good which makes us feel
bad
i've heard what makes you cheer i'm eric
voss my easter egg breakdown of all the
details he missed is coming tomorrow but
here
i'm with a co-host who totally cuts to
chat tommy bechtold
hey yeah we're back uh
i'll be honest i didn't do as much this
episode so that was right
or something yeah step in the right
direction for sure
yeah we're about halfway through this we
are halfway through this season now so
at the end of the episode tommy and i
will kind of go into
our general state of the season thoughts
um
but for right now before we dive into
what this whole galactus killing really
means for the universe
tommy break down what exactly happened
this episode absolutely i hope you are a
fan
of 80s movies because if you are not you
may also be asking yourself wtf about
this episode
rick has to suffer through a karaoke
night with jerry to pay a debt to
hellraiser cenobites who get off on
rick's suffering
by turning purple or whatever color that
was it
just oh my god there was so much weird
oh so good
jerry realizes he's the butt of the joke
and stops playing along
so the cenobites drag him to hell really
just to lure rick into a trap to torture
rick with jerry
meanwhile in order to win the new guy
bruce chuck back
morty and summer
joy riding in rick's car who argues with
them in the keep summer safe voice the
car takes over the night
and hunts a galactus and then flirts
with the change formers
grossed out at her just being a car oh
what do they call her she's a
non-changer
it throws up all over her oh my god
throws up the oil so good
yeah they grossed out they're just being
cars so she massacres them in space
tahoe they get arrested and the car
tries to pin it all on bruce which i
thought was a great plan
yeah but it ends up blowing up the jail
yeah beth and rick
break jerry free from hell by
weaponizing the cenobites pleasure pain
against them bruce jepec ditches morty
and summer but then at school gets made
fun of
for wearing the same pair of pants two
days in a row which by the way
if that was a rule i would have been the
least popular kid in school because i
wore those jeans for
months baby which like you have to know
everyone who's writing the show is aware
of that like
it's such a stupid thing to get made fun
of for but if someone does notice it you
don't really have a defense it's like
i don't want to wash jeans every night
yeah
washing denim every day what are we
aristocrats not in this economy
but i'm wearing a different shirt with
it that's right
yeah i wear i wear a different color of
the same shirt from kohl's and that
makes me cool
don't you know the top half of our body
sweat more than the lower half of our
bodies it's just science
not me not thanks to blue chew and
manscaped uh
all right two sponsors that i don't know
if they're doing this episode
all right and then finally
ten things off he gets jumped by the
mailboxes
yep they got their revenge yes i love it
yeah a lot to dig into this episode like
the secret life of rick's car i never
thought this voice would return
in such a plot driving capacity um so i
want to talk more about what it means
that she killed a galactus but
first if you want to help us make more
great content at new rockstars like
where explained one of the best ways
that you can support us is to check out
our merch at newrockstarsmerch.com
we got some brand new black
widow-inspired designs in the shop
including our latest obsession the red
deep design and some fun russian nesting
doll designs support this channel get
yourself some cool swag by going to
newrockstarsmerch.com
all right tommy what's our big question
eric why does rick's car
kill galactus because it's awesome
because if you can why wouldn't you
yes right absolutely good night
everybody that's all we have to
do uh so when rick's car takes over the
joyride
uh she goes fishing for a giant space
deity that's clearly modeled on galactus
the devourer of worlds from marvel
comics by luring him it looks like with
the solar system
although based off of the proportion of
the car to the solar system it must be a
real
small one yeah uh and galactus is
actually smaller here than he would be
in uh in marvel lore he's huge but after
killing him she does this like measuring
him like a sport fish yeah that says
it's too small and thrown back
but implying that she has hunted other
larger galactus before
and she says rick never lets me do this
which to me was the fascinating line
like
rick knows better than to go after
galactus is for some reason like he has
some kind of like
line of demarcation when it comes to
galactuses that he doesn't want to cross
or he just has specific galactus hunting
license or galactus fishing rights
and he doesn't want to pay a fine to
whatever the international fishing
wildlife foundation is or
interdimensional
you have to only have certain seasons
where you can check galactus
you can catch you can catch a 85 000
foot galactus between
may and july but outside of that they
have to be a hundred
thousand feet that's what the right is i
think uh-huh it's like a population
control right which is
two layers of population control they
control population by devouring
dying worlds right and just kind of like
kind of being the custodian of the
universe
so you got to be a proper custodian to
them you know you know what
it doesn't sound so bad when you say it
like that
uh i also like how there is kind of a
fun parallel where rick's uh cinebite
form
is like another sport fish a marlin
that's used for his torso
like i don't know if there's some kind
of connection there but um
we know that rick's car of course was
deadly all the way back in season two
the ricks must be crazy episode keep
some are safe
where you know it's just murdering
people it the worst thing it did i think
was psychotically
resurrect the false version of that
cop's son who would die
and then melts in his arms and screams
it was horrific um but it ended up
brokering a piece between humanity and
the
telepathic spiders um but this car is
genius and you could argue that it has
the same
intelligence that rick's had rick just
programmed it with an ai but i think
it's just creepy this whole time for all
the things that have happened in this
car
the car has witnessed it the car has
seen it the car can talk
the car kind of has its own personality
its own soul one could argue
uh so where does that come from and why
is it not always
uh complaining i assume rick has it in
his programming
but uh i would say that based off of the
fact that this car is killing a galactus
means that it is even more bloodthirsty
uh because rick had a reason not to do
it the car has a reason to do it
um and let's also not forget that
for everything horrible rick has done
with this car the car has enabled him to
do it like
last season where they kind of became
terrorists and bombed the hell out of
that glorzo world with the facehuggers
yeah like that was a huge step it
invaded the towers it
avoided a 911 reference but then did a
pearl harbor reference because that was
okay
that's right oh my god
we're messed up that's so crazy but i
think
to me one thing that's easy to forget
about this car is that it is powered by
the microverse battery
which i argue might give it its own
promethean
god complex oh right because yeah i
think if forever keeping the lights on
in this car
is actually stephen colbert's character
the uh the zeb zamplor
guy's name and that episode ended with
him just like on one of these treadmills
eternally bitter toward
his god rick right so you have this kind
of like
layer upon layer of promethean hatred
uh and my theory is that that is the
source of the car's unique
deity bloodthirst and that we of course
we know rick himself loves killing gods
this isn't
that different like we saw him kill a
zeus last season episode two and his
decoys talked about wanting to kill the
christian god this isn't anything new
but the fact that the car is okay with
killing galactuses and the fact that
you know terrifyingly more than one
exists in this universe
right just tells me that this particular
action doesn't come from rick's
programming i think it comes from
this car's ghost in the machine and that
could be a soul that is kind of
derived from the microverse battery
sentiment
i mean that would be uh terrifying for
the future
of uh of this season and with in future
seasons of the show
if this car is just kind of if if it's
beyond rick's control
cause that's kind of like the basis for
like i guess the control of the entire
show is that rick has invented all of
this tech
so it does kind of obey his commands and
when it goes out of control he generally
has like a destroy
sequence or a self-destruct sequence
built in so if this is a rogue
rick invention we uh we we might be in
some real trouble
or the the rick and morty universe might
be in some real trouble yeah agreed
um now i think you saw that episode
seven was like
accidentally released uh early did you
have a chance to watch it yet
i did not okay i have watched it i'm not
gonna
talk about it until that week comes up
so i know a lot of you guys keep
tweeting me don't worry i've seen it i
know what happens in the episode
if you haven't seen it there's a lot to
look forward to coming up
but surprisingly there are continuity
things that i thought would never come
back on the show that do
come back that episode and almost kind
of a cosmic um
in a cosmic setting which make me think
like in upcoming episodes like the
vindicators which is going to happen
this season
things like killed galactuses might not
be a one and done joke
that's something that could set up the
plot of the vindicators episode
yeah i i think that there's i've been i
mean we're going to talk about the
season more
there's there's a lot of loose threads
right now and and i know this show's not
obligated to
pull on those threads ever but it feels
like
the way thing i'm so sorry my phone is
going absolutely crazy i have it on
silent
there there feels like i know the show's
not beholden to pawn threads but it
feels like this year specifically
they're setting up a lot of really cool
things to return to or very disturbing
things to turn to
in uh regards to incest babies giant
incest babies in space
uh yeah but i also think things that are
sort of marvel related that does tend to
come back a lot i think because of the
show's connection with the writing staff
of these marvel shows
they came from rick and morty uh in a
lot of cases and i think
uh dan harmon and company are leaning
into that uh
that parallel so i think they enjoy kind
of making light or making fun of or just
abruptly killing off
elements that evoke the marvel cinematic
universe and i know galactus isn't in
there yet but
right probably will be soon um but uh
yeah i'm excited to see
uh what affects killing or hunting
galactuses could have i think we're
always surprised by the scale
of rick's power in the in the power of
rick's tech like
when he fought the zeus i was like holy
crap there is no limit to his power
yeah for sure he is essentially a god
right um
but the fact that they are now bringing
in actual forms of these things whether
they're from religion
or from the uh or from comics lore
is just fascinating to see who else
they're gonna bring in there i mean you
could argue the fact that they
have fought things like scary terry you
know and they're fighting these
cinebites now
that like they're not afraid of fighting
um demonic entities
no not at all in fact they almost
embrace it all right
well we want to talk more about this
episode but first some people helped us
make this episode our friends at
bluechew have a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost
bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluetooth.com consult
with one of their licensed medical
providers and once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
there licensed medical providers work
with you to find the right ingredient in
strength and if you hate swallowing
pills good news blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name
so if you could benefit from some extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free you want to
use our promo code ricksplained at
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com go to
explain to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode uh this show is also sponsored
by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals we've all been
there at some point
betterhelp will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
start communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line or self-help and
it is professional counseling
done securely online there's a broad
range of expertise available for clients
worldwide
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor you won't ever
have to sit in a comfortable waiting
room or look for parking
better help makes it easy and free to
change counselors if you need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today visit betterhelp.com
ricksplained that's better help and join
the over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for rick's playing
audience get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
ricksplain and thanks to helix for
sponsoring the show whether your day job
is being a master of the mystic arts a
billionaire playboy philanthropist or an
accountant
at the end of the day you want to sleep
in a bed designed to fit your specific
needs
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
ideal mattress for you they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size sleepers i took the quiz i got
matched with a dusk lux helix mattress
a medium firm beauty with lumbar support
that sleeps cool
i've been slumbering like a boss since i
got it like a voss
the mattress ships right to your door
for free you never need to go to a
mattress store again
they were awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq and
wired magazine
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners
at helixsleep.com explained that's helix
sleep.com
rick's blade all right tommy uh back to
the episode here
let's read too much into rick's journey
into hell with the cinebites
is rick having to suffer through jerry's
cringiness
a hell of his own making because they
say
the cringe would not exist unless it's
observed but are we also to believe
based off of the set of bites logic that
rick might take
pleasure a kind of pleasure from this
pain of jerry
i i think that we get a little crack
into rick's
shell you know when he's down in hell
talking to to uh to jerry that
it was i mean it was rick's idea to pay
this debt with jerry right was it i mean
it wasn't that what
was explained so it's like i mean he
rick surely could have thought of
another way to set like
he could have designed a monitor that
just played
cringy you know viral videos at these
at these uh hell beings but i think rick
also pointed out that like
this and this episode the writers of
this episode rather do a great job
pointing out that like
hellraiser is really silly it's a really
really silly
no offense to giant hellraiser fans it's
a really silly premise for a horror
movie
that succeeds because pinhead is so
terrifying looking
like to younger people you're like this
is a terrifying looking
you know villain or whatever but like i
think
i think that rick is i think he does
kind of
secretly maybe take a little bit of joy
out of jerry's corniness you know like
it does
maybe on some level looking at cringy
stuff there's a reason why people do it
there's a reason why they go viral and
the reason why we share it it's like
we all cringe and it's kind of like a
jump scare it's like there's a feeling
that comes out of it
and then the feeling afterwards that
maybe is pleasurable to people
i never kink shame but my personal kink
is
uh apple commercials that make me cry
when fathers and sons are reunited
so what do i do
yeah i like when it comes to like cringe
humor there's like kind of a almost like
a sign wave to it
you know like as a kid you uh
start to like you start by loving it
when your dad makes these jokes
but then you reach like teenage years
and you start to like hate it
yeah but then like at some point at some
point you start to become like
aware of it and you start to own it
yourself and lean into it so it goes
back up again
yeah but then you like you know you have
your first really
awful breakup and nothing makes you
laugh and only like really dark
up stuff makes you laugh so then you
hate cringe humor again uh and you start
to like go with like rick's nihilism
and then at some point you just reach a
state of nirvana in bliss towards all
things and any
uh evidence of like happiness uh you
appreciate
and i think maybe that's if you start
having kids and then you
experience joy vicariously through them
so you start to love and you are now the
one making the dad jokes
uh i think we need and then you reach a
point of yeah i think so then you reach
old age where like
um you lose your job and you don't have
health insurance or
like your kids hate you because of your
political beliefs or something like that
so then you hate everything that's funny
and you don't get anything and you're on
twitter
responding to everything sincerely and
then you just
have dimension yeah then you then you're
diagnosed with something terminally
awful but the only the only thing that
you think is funny is like jesse waters
on fox news you're like that guy
freaking crushes people uh that's gonna
anger
even that's gonna anger some people i'm
sorry sorry no jesse waters
our huge following of jesse waters fans
out there but
i mean there's only one and i don't
think jesse watches this show that's
okay
[Music]
shout out to jay watts if you're
watching all right sorry
next question uh when morty turns on
interdimensional cable
there's a commercial for story train on
does that mean right
that episode was not canon yeah we were
talk we talked about this last season
that was episode six of season four
um where that truly felt like one
episode that might be removed from the
main continuity
uh just because that was kind of the
theme of the episode of what is
canonicity
and rick and morty uh and if it is not
canon does it have
uh stakes to the fate of the characters
and their
you know and their journeys um i think
that is kind of the implication of this
that a story train is a toy that you can
buy from a commercial and
interdimensional cable
that at the end of that episode that was
kind of like uh
morty and rick doing kind of lego movie
thing
yeah like putting their imaginations in
the story train and kind of imagining
what they were doing as they were
playing with it right but i don't think
that makes the emotional stakes
any uh lesser yeah because like as long
as it
captivates you and connects with you
while you're on the train
so to speak while you're watching a show
right then if it transports you in that
moment if it transports you even for a
second
it's done its job i agree you know yeah
so
i i think some people say filler or
throwaway episodes when that happens
i don't know if i can like forget about
my life for a second
and and be surprised by where the story
goes for a second
i i think that's uh that's enough for me
yeah i i think we've got to as
viewers learn to embrace the like you
say throw away episodes or filler
episodes like
to the creative team there's meaning
behind it and it's kind of
up to us like we can choose to be
cynical about it and be like well they
just needed to get
another episode in or we can enjoy
what's in front of us and feel something
like you said and to me
choosing option b is always going to be
more fulfilling like
rather than just being like you know
well this didn't matter
so i don't care about it like you know
we can still care about the characters
and what happens and we still care about
you know how it makes us feel and if it
makes us laugh or makes us think so
there's value in those episodes and
that's you know uh
you see this a lot with rick and morty
but it's with every fan base really
people say like well didn't do enough to
win me over right i don't know i think
the way we watch these shows uh in these
movies it
is a choice to frame our expectations a
certain way
when we sit down for these things it is
our choice what our attitude is going
into it
uh are we are we going to allow
ourselves to be entertained and
impressed
or are we going to cross our arms and
say impress me
like you don't that's not on the show
that's on you you know that's
your attitude your approach to the world
is totally in your control
uh and the world isn't going to come to
you and win you over
you have to be open to it you got to be
vulnerable and you got to
be ready to uh to enjoy something you
have to allow yourself to appreciate
exactly so put on your parents old
records give the kinks a try
give give the the moody blues a try
you know stop being so cynical whatever
i think of moody blues i think of that
simpsons episode where homer and
flanders go to vegas then the moody
blues
i got fatty well
i would say arguably the character gets
punished the most this episode is bruce
shut back who i think that was darren
chris who voiced him yes
um and it was specifically for the way
he bailed on morty and summer but this
is
after they refused to bail on him they
were going to put it all on him in that
jail
and they're like no bruce like you just
they have some lie about him being
slack-jawed just enough and it's not his
fault
you know they have been through so much
they know not to punish the innocents of
the world for just being
innocent and stupid right but then at
the end he screws him over
so i think it's right to see him get
mocked so much
he has to get him but i wonder
thematically what this tells us is the
show's saying that the greatest crime
one could commit is betraying
those who stuck out their neck for you i
don't think so
because if that was the case that rick
would be dead
but well i would say rick suffers though
richard you're right
you know you're right he does pay he
does rick does suffer
massive consequences he just drinks them
away so that they're right
they don't haunt him but i think this
was more of just like the rule of always
sunny in philadelphia which is
if you don't screw someone over
inevitably by the end of the episode
they have to screw you over
as a lesson to learn that you need to
always look out for number one
like that's just like yeah that's like
the the prime directive of that show and
i feel like this episode just followed
those rules
right yeah i one thing that like was
kind of a depressing take away from this
episode is that just by
being yourself that's not enough the
world is still going to torture you
right being yourself and like it's not
enough to expect the world not to
torture you for being yourself you just
have to like
get over it and exactly like whether
it's jerry's
cringe humor he can't control it it's
his essence or the fact that bruce
jetpack wears the same pair of pants to
school so that we all did and like it's
one of
it i think that was kind of a
placeholder for all of us going through
high school
heist was terrible and whether it was
wearing two pairs of pants the same day
in the row
or like your shoes not being right or
something like that they're gonna find
something uh the monsters of high school
will punish you yes
for sure uh so it's kind of a hell on
earth take away what it is right yeah
but it's it's true it's very true and
then uh mailboxes from another planet
will come kick your ass
well which who hasn't that happened to
yeah
absolutely well tommy we're halfway
through season five already it's kind of
moving pretty fast
um but luckily unlike last season we
don't have to like take a
months-long break now we're getting on
episode six seven eight nine ten
yeah so what are your general thoughts
on this season compared to you know
uh there have i mean it's been all over
the place
you know obviously we had one of the
most disgusting episodes although
something really fascinating over the
last week
has been the feedback i've gotten from
friends of mine
that are rick and morty fans the older
people that i know that are fans like
people in their late 30s 40s
loved that episode and thought it was
really funny and we're not disgusted by
it
everyone under that age was to sit was
like this was too disgusting i
crossed the line that i couldn't really
like pay as much attention to the
episode as i normally would or take as
much enjoyment out of it so that was
really interesting to me
because i kind of am right in the middle
of that and i was kind of like i was
grossed out by it maybe not as much as
others
like you know in the moment i was as i
looked thought about it more i'm like oh
i mean
there was a lot of disgusting things but
it's like it's rick and morty like
half of the aliens are shaped like
buttholes you know what i mean like what
are we
we're kind of being selective about what
grosses us out
overall for the season though uh i think
that what they've done is put
so many good potential things out there
with already fulfilling episodes first
episode with mr nimbus
i want more of mr nimbus i want more of
that story but that was a great episode
planeteen episode same thing i want her
to come back
in the vindicators episode i hope that
she returns for that
so there's there's a lot of things i
want to see more but i'm already very
satisfied with what those characters and
what those stories have given us so
i would say they're doing a great job
but i'm very excited to see what the
second half has
how about you yeah i've enjoyed this
season um you know i
all the jokes on the show are really
great yeah uh i think there's been a few
times where
the either the b plot or in some cases
even the a plot didn't have the
the typical rick and morty story
structure curvature
that like maybe it's just nostalgia
being
seen through rose tinted glasses you
know and i'm just remembering
only the best stuff from seasons one two
and three sure um
but uh every season has had some
episodes that are just like
a goofy concept explored for 22 minutes
and then we're done and then we get out
of it we don't go back to it
uh which i was okay with like i'm
someone who discovered rick and morty
like in 2014 or 2015 and i was able to
binge all of it on adult swim
yeah you know so i was spoiled by those
seasons and then that kind of primed my
view of the series
and i didn't ever have like a whole week
where i was like man i just had a not as
great episode of rick and morty
to me i just saw it as a whole so i'm
trying to just see the series as a whole
still
uh and and not be to you know have too
high of expectations for it
uh but what i am waiting for this season
is something like what we saw with the
fat of acid episode last year
yes it started it's just kind of a dumb
kind of like trope that someone in the
writers room probably noticed like why
do all these
things have that so why does tim
burton's batman have these open vats of
acid
right um and not just tim burns batman
the typical joker origin story yeah of
course but um
it it evolved into something so profound
and heartbreaking and i love when rick
and morty does that like planet tina
episode did that
i felt uh i would even say like the the
narnia dimension episode like that so
much story was packed
but what did we say 14 generations of
story yeah i mean it was wrong
yeah yeah so uh i love when they can do
that where it's not just starts with
like kind of a goofy thing and they
explore it at the surface level
but it uh evolves into something
different and
they started to get there this episode
with like when rick started to really do
the math on the pleasure equals pain
uh inversion device and these
as they're getting hit with the laser
they're kind of confused with what their
emotion is
but uh it i did lose me for a little bit
but not in the way of like me being
towed behind the car as it's going off
in a crazy place it was more
like
me chasing after the car being like wait
wait what what are we doing now like
sure
sure i get that uh so i felt that a few
times this season
but uh i still really love the show and
every episode does something that
surprises me in a really fun way yeah
absolutely i'll say this uh haven't seen
episode seven
it's great it's one of the best of the
season compared to
we'll keep watching fine i guess twist
my arm i'll be making fun
yeah uh so there's a lot to look forward
to and i appreciate everyone who's been
sticking with us
like rick and morty's such a fun show we
it's hard for us to cover stuff that's
not marvel here because it is a huge
risk
to cover smaller audience properties
because we have like employees that like
this is their jobs it's not like hobbies
where i can just cover
you know a season of dark on netflix
which is what i would want to do break
down
you know even something that like hbo's
watchmen which i love
i can't always cover it so rick and
morty is just one that like we're able
to cover there's enough people who
really love it
and uh it fits our brand of like clue
hunting and easter egg hunting and
theorizing in the right ways
well i just want to go back real quick
there are people that get paid to do
this because i've been getting just
little snickers bars sent in the mail to
me
so is there you get snickers bars yeah
see i'm working off a debt
um horrible thing that i did and i can't
describe it but
is that why you take me partying with
those demons every week
oh man am i jerry in this situation
uh see i thought i was a jerry in this
i assume i'm the jerry at every party
well uh that is it for this episode of
explained my easter egg breakdown of all
the little details you missed
will be coming out tomorrow tommy and i
will be back next week to react to
episode six
so be sure to follow tommy at tommy beck
told follow me at ea boss follow new
rockstars subscribe to explain wherever
you get your podcasts
thank you for watching and we'll close
with our favorite moment of the episode
isn't it a doorknob a virgin
not mine never the doorknob
[Music]
you